In Syria, rebels say they have received more supplies of US-made weapons...
...to battle forces of President Bashar al-Assad.
In Colombia, a breakthrough deal was unveiled to determine the fate...
...of the tens of thousands of people missing and presumed dead...
...during a half-century of war.
In the Philippines, typhoon Koppu kills at least nine people...
...with tens of thousands forced from their homes.
Several thousand migrants remain stranded along the Croatian-Serbian border...
...after Hungary shut down its crossing into Croatia.
And finally from Indonesia, forest fires that are creating haze across Southeast Asia...
...continue to spread and are unlikely to be put out before next year.